we got to talk Facebook because it seems
that the world has had it with Facebook
people are over it and I've seen this
coming for quite some time people are
not happy with their new app you know
they came out with the with the Facebook
phone people don't like that usership
trending downwards and then of course
this whole thing where they were gonna
take over the search business from from
Google and Bing and all that that has
just fallen flat they do have 1.1
billion users but more and more people
as I said are just not into it people
don't care whose birthday it is they're
not sharing stuff like they used to and
liking stuff like they used to so is
this just like because it became so
freakin corporate is that like the main
thing going on here it just became this
giant business where at first it was
like this little fun thing and now it
just feels like this endless machine it
was fun it was fun at first because it
was just it was a college thing right it
was like being a little a crew you know
you had your own little fun thing but
yeah I think it stopped being fun when
my mom you brought it up earlier and
again yeah mom get out of my head but no
like I've moved on I've moved on to to
Twitter I think Twitter is the place to
be
vine is the new hotness right yeah
six-second did I say new hotness is that
100 that was a that was a bi sure you
don't like another thing to join I can't
keep up for comedians for for
entertainers that's a great thing you
work out material in six second
increments right it's become very
obvious to me since I've been doing the
show that comedians love the one-way
communication we love Twitter cuz we're
just putting it out all the time and you
and vine and all that but Facebook it's
like I actually deleted my facebook page
I have a fan page and that's fine I post
one thing a day but I couldn't deal with
all the narcissist you just have a fan
page you know not a friendly there was
it part of getting all of your friends
to become I've lost some friends yeah
but what do you I mean it seems to me
Facebook is on the way out like it I
think it actually started with the movie
2 because the movie to me like made it
you know the social network it made it
seem so dirty right how the whole thing
was created yeah that I just had this
taste in my mouth after like I just
don't like anything about this look
behind and you see the great powerful oz
is just this little old man going don't
ya the curtain man I think people are
just disenchanted right away yeah like
oh that's what it is
ah all right and my dad's on it yeah you
know my parents are on it and I do have
to watch what I post because I don't
want to look I have a grown woman I have
a mortgage I have a child I'm still
concerned about my parents think about
me and they cyberstalk me like no
they're watching this right now I
guarantee it
not because I told them because what
they see on the or thing but they're
like the slowest cyber stalkers like
they'll watch like a week later and be
like I saw you today you did the thing
no that was a week ago but good luck
thanks for playing that is true you know
actually come to think of it my dad
every now and again will call me like a
week after I tweeted something I don't
care if I really mean it I got the the
you know the results that I wanted I
think it's here to stay though don't you
think it's gonna stay you don't think
it's going the way of myspace like that
it'll just eventually crumble and then
something else something else but it'll
it'll stick around
it will stay it will be like the phone
book for a very long time I still get
the phone book delivered to my house
what do you do with it it's just a prop
up a kid when you have a kid over to
somebody idea actually I mean what else
would one do with the phone book you
actually open a phone book and go well
I'm gonna look for a plumber I mean I
just start reading it and people and say
this is what you get for still having
your number in a phone book but I don't
what we'll just it'll be there it'll be
there Facebook will not go away easily
yeah it will still be around but we will
move on let me ask if you guys could do
just a digital reset if you could just
press a button one time and just clear
out the whole freaking thing and start
over would you do
it um no I wouldn't do it you mean with
everywhere the whole thing if you just
the whole that kind of sounds what I'm
talking about we are gonna have kool-aid
passed out shortly and we're going down
know if you could just press a button
and reset the whole thing so that all
your all your digital footprint whatever
that is your your Twitter your Facebook
the whole thing could just reset and you
could start a new my life would be
completely different I get into so much
trouble in my old relationship in my
current relationship always in trouble
for being on the phone but it's really
well it's candy crush saga now I think
more than anything else I do I'd go
bonkers for I can't believe I just
submitted that cut this out you're not
this part no no it's dang it's um I did
a I did a tweet which I thought was very
funny
it makes fun of disease muscle atrophy
right on Twitter I really fun it but
it's funny on Twitter right so I wrote a
first person to lose all their muscle
mass wins a trophy a trophy you know
it's funny when you read it I put that
on Facebook and three people that I went
to high school with have kids with
muscle as well you shouldn't write that
and I go no it's a it's a joke I look at
my timeline everything I write is
nonsense so that's why Facebook for me
yeah is really just a place for me to
look at baby pictures so maybe that's
part of time that Facebook has become
this like personal thing versus Twitter
is like just this oh I used to have my
Twitter connected to my facebook Yeah
right who couldn't have been happy about
no yeah immediately I took I realized
what am i doing these are different
people it is like like you said your
high school friends it's like those
friends that you have and then you go
off to summer camp and it's those
friends that you have you know like
Twitter is like those bad and they get
you on a different level and you can't
mix the two you just can't mean
sometimes yes there's an overlap but
hardly anyone on my facebook is also on
my Twitter yeah alright commenter is a
camera Sultana [ __ ] and get to it and
we'll make sure we forward everything
over to her personally
you